welcome to the reproductive health track
on day one of the apj genetic solution
tour
2020 my name is michael richardson
and i will be your moderator for this
session during this session
we will focus on the use of next
generation sequencing technology
for expanded carrier screening
applications pre-implantation genetic
testing for aneuploides
as well as monogenic disorders as a
reminder if you have any questions for
our speakers
please submit them in the q a box
and our speaker will address your
questions following the presentation
our first speaker today is dr maheen
saleem
dr mohamed saleem the laboratory
director
at genomics lab in malaysia dr saleem
received his phd in medical genetics
from the university putra malaysia
in 2011 and undertook a postdoctoral
fellowship
working on acute myeloid leukemia and
pharmacogenomics
at the university sans malaysia dr salim
has been working in the field of genetic
diagnostics since 2011
and in 2016 he joined genomics lab as
the laboratory director
genomics lab is a private molecular
diagnostics company
providing genetic testing services that
specialise in reproductive genetics and
cancer genetic testing
today dr celine will be sharing with us
his experience with
expanded carrier screening and he will
be providing an overview
about bringing expanded carrier
screening in-house
using next-generation sequencing
technology
i welcome dr saleem to give his
presentation
thank you very much so what i would like
to do today is to share our experience
using expanded carrier screening essay
at genomics lab
this is my disclosure slide
so at genomics lab our main area of
services
are in the domains of reproductive
genetics and cancer genetic testing
under the reproductive genetic testing
domain we offer multiple
small carrier screening panels for
reproductive partners to screen them
for autosomal responsive disorders kd
screening
uh at genomics lab is mainly aimed at
identifying couples who are at increased
risk of having an
affected child in order to facilitate
informed
reproductive decision making in the past
we offer the targeted carrier screening
and
we use many different approaches like a
little specific pcr for
point mutations gap pcr for large
deletions
in alpha globin gene for example small
ngs panels and a series of mlpa
reactions for
copy number changes as many would agree
there are multiple challenges in these
panels
especially custom-made panels as it only
addresses to some
handful of common autosomal recessive
disorders in the local population
it does not screen for rare genetic
changes
and mostly designed for hotspot testing
it is also laborious to perform multiple
protocols
and since our populations are made up of
many subpopulations
these small panels are not fit for all
ethnic groups
and that make up a population so
we need an expanded carrier screening
approach to serve
these couples better in understanding
the risk of
having an affected child when they are
planning a family
uh
having said that uh in spite of this
smaller panels that we use
uh using multiple approaches of
cardiogenetic testing
we at genomics lab observe that about 48
of individuals tested for carrier
screening
are carriers for at least one autosomal
resistance condition
and out of them about 4.5 of the couples
are carriers for mutations on
on the same gene so when a couple has
got
the same mutation on a different uh or
different variant on the same gene
there will be about 25 percent risk that
each
pregnancy would be affected with either
homozygous or compound heterozygous
offspring
so our main aim would be to reduce this
unfortunate event for these couples and
inform these couples that
of their risks ahead of the planned
pregnancy
counsel them appropriately and provide
them
with reproductive options so that the
couples can make
better informed decisions uh planning a
healthy family
so the general approach for the couples
in this category with a mutation would
be
to offer pgtm for them
after gen of course after genetic
counseling
now the numbers presented here may
change if an expanded kg screening was
offered to
uh our couples and may add on uh
extra prevention for more couples
[Music]
to prevent birth of affected children
and their families
um so our lab had early access to
expanded carrier screening panel called
carrier sick from thermo fish scientific
we have already analyzed about 80
samples using this panel
and uh it gives us a very promising
result
uh this emphasis based panel combines uh
many standalone tests into a single
assay
that contains 420 genes of
covering entire coding regions including
about 25 base pair into the flanking
extra intronics on boundaries
the panel is designed to detect at least
more than 28 000 non-benign clinical
clinvar variants
including both single nucleotide
variants and copy number changes
unlike many other expanded carrier
sequencing panel
unlike many other expanded carrier
sequencing panels out in the market
this cadillac panel include the
difficulty sequence genes
due to pseudogenes and homology between
parallax
such as smn1 for spinal muscular atrophy
and hpa1 and hpa2 for alpha thalassemia
gba for gaucher disease c21a2 for 21
hydroxylase
deficient congenital adrenal hydroplasia
so this ready to implement workflow
contains
optimized reagents and customizable
cardiac reporter software
for data analysis and reporting so we
find that this is a very useful product
for reproductive genetic testing in our
lab
so the integration of kt workflow in our
lab
was seamlessly easy uh
these those labs using and physical
workflow will find it easy to
especially if your lab is doing a whole
exam sequencing library because
both are very similar in the
weight library preparation so this slide
shows
the steps involved in emphasis screening
workflow and the expected time we spent
in each stage
the beauty of this product starts at the
library prep
because you will be preparing a single
library for both the
single nucleotide variants and copy
number changes
and therefore it is extremely appealing
because otherwise we will be doing a
series of mlpa reactions that require
overnight hybridization and multiple pcr
reactions for different
other mutation testing and also involves
more than one staff to handle these
procedures but
uh with the introduction of uh
careerstick workflow in our lab
it has changed the way we approach
career screening for couples
testing so we start the library prep in
the morning and by the end of our eight
hour shift
the libraries are ready for automated
overnight template preparation
that includes isothermal amplification
enrichment of
the ion sphere particles and chip
loading
so this will take about 13 to 14 hours
including
the hands-on times so the next morning
when you come for work
the chips are loaded and ready for
sequencing
and with the use of iron s5 system the
sequencing is completed within about
two hours 45 minutes per chip and data
is ready within about six to eight hours
after the sequencing of the chip
so all in all the entire process from
library prep
to reporting will take about two and a
half to three days
in total
[Music]
so this slide the slide shows some
run qc metrics from a typical carrier 6
run on an s5 sequencer the total number
of bases is
16.6 g with an isp loading of
87 percent uh the
particular this particular run has
achieved over 88 million reads
which is more than a theoretical maximum
for a 540 chip in general
and the polyclonals are way below the
threshold of about 30 percent
um the observed mean rate length is uh
about 188 base pair which is more than
the minimum 150
base pair for the good accurate
downstream analysis
the expected number of reads for example
is about four to five million and this
amount is
important to call the copy number
variance accurately
and the other qc metrics are mean depth
which should be more than 200 times but
if you look at here it's about more than
300 times
uh oral and the uniformity expected is
more than 93
but in this run it is more than 94 so
overall this is a very healthy run for
downstream data analysis
for copy number variations and mutation
analysis
uh expand the workflow also comes with a
pre-configured pipeline in the iron
reporter software for
automatic calling of single nucleotide
variants
indels and copy number changes so we
don't have to heavily depend on the
in-house bioinformations to
make sense of all these variants coming
from over 400 genes
so it's a very easy workflow in the
wet lab and also in the dry lab
so expanded kt screening also comes with
a very user friendly carrier reporter
software
it gives the flexibility to add your own
header and footer
analysis uh could be done on uh
cloud version or on a local server but
at our lab
we use the cloud version and the
experience was as good as a
local server server and software also
handles a dige
variant analysis for example southeast
asian deletion which removes
both hp a1 and hpa2 uh
other divisions like mediterranean or
thai divisions
uh on both hp a1 and hpa2
so it really is a wonderful software
that is associated with the expanded
carrier screening workflow
and we find it extremely user friendly
and
easy to report and they are easy to
analyze the data
and this is a typical report generator
from the carrier 6 reporter software
you can add your own header and footer
of your institution as i have done
here and you can add your client
information and extra
etc the software uses bright colors
color boxes to indicate different types
of variants
pink color is used for explained
disorders as shown on the
left bottom of the screen orange color
for compound heterozygous changes
as shown on the top right of the screen
and the yellow color represents the
autosomal carrier status
as as shown on the right bottom of your
screen
so i have two cases to present
because of the time constraint i only
will limit only two cases so this is
case number one
it's a chinese couple no non-constrained
units marriage no family history of
genetic disorder
up to two generations so the only thing
they have found noticeable is that when
they did the
complete black count the mcv was a bit
marginally low
in both husband and wife so they they
all
they were offered expanded carriers
clinic not because of the low in cv
count but the engine for the general
screening expenditure carrier was
offered for this couple
so for the husband uh
there is a husband is a carrier for
single gene deletion and alpha global
gene so with a 4.2 deletion
so he is a carrier for alpha thalassemia
and wife is also a carrier for alpha
thalassemia but this white has got a
double gene deletion called southeast
asian division which
removes both alpha hpa1 and hpa2 gene
complex
and white is also having another
mutation on
uh that results in hemochromatosis type
one
but the important finding for this
couple is that both are carriers for
alpha thalassemia
uh husband has a single gene deletion
wife has got a double gene deletion so
therefore
there's an increased risk of about 25
chance
of this couple having an hph disease
which will cause
a moderate degree of anemia microcytosis
and
sometimes occasionally or medical blood
transfusion for this couple
so after genetic counseling the couple
opted to do ivfl
and pgta and pgtm and you can see the
results at the bottom of your screen and
they had five embryos from the ivf cycle
the first
embryo is a euploid embryo with a 4.2
deletion so this embryo will be a
carrier for alpha thalassemia
with a single gene division embryo
number two is euphoid
and the alpha thalassemia alpha globin
gene complex is completely normal
embryo number four is again euphoid with
hemoglobin hdc so this is the embryo
this is the type of embryo
or the pregnancy that we are trying to
avoid by
giving the opportunity to do pgdm
carrier screening followed by pgtm so
this couple um i was implanted with
embryo number two and have a healthy
pregnancy on going now
this is uh case number two where uh it's
a consensus marriage
from an indian malaysian ethnic group
and they report families they have
immediate history of a child
they have lost a child at the age of one
with
liver disorders and presumptive
diagnosis was warm and disease
so the couple was offered a carrier
screening and then
we noticed that the there's a point
mutation in the lipa gene both husband
and wife carry the same mutation
and probably this is because of the
cancer unit's marriage between them
so again this couple was offered pgt
a and pgdm and this couple had got three
embryos
embryo number one is a euploid a
homozygous normal
uh embryo number two and three are you
uh aneuploid so they cannot use this
embryo and luckily this couple has got
one embryo that is completely
euphoid and uh mutation free on the
lipper gene
so this shows that uh real genetic
variants especially these
private mutations can be found in any
ethnic groups
and any population and expanded kg skin
would
help such couples and give hope for a
healthy family
so immediately immediate use of kerystik
at genomics lab is
we will be using this as a laboratory
develop test mainly to screen
against sperm donors and also this panel
will be used for cardiac screening for
couples to access their risk of
developing an abnormal
genetic disorder baby so some of the
benefits
of using expanded carrier screening is
that it is an excellent tool that
focuses on the risk assessment of
individual conditions and this panel is
a
pan-ethnic panel which is suitable for
multi-ethnic
sub-populations like malaysia and india
and it's been easy to integrate the
workflow into our routine level lab
vet lab and the dry lab and one of the
limitations that is
shared amongst most of the expanded
categories feeling that it is uh
not able to analyze the repeat expansion
diseases like fragile x syndrome
uh any uh and other myotonic dystrophies
or spinal uh
cerebral atexia kind of repeat
expansions
so these are common limitations for all
expanded carrier screenings
and so with that
i will conclude my presentation and
thank you very much for the opportunity
given multiplication to share our
experience on expanded carry spending
thank you very much
thank you dr celine for that very
engaging presentation
and sharing your experience with us
excuse me
i will now open the session for
questions and
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q and a
box okay let me just
go to the questions
okay we've got a few questions coming
through and the first question
we have dr celine is that towards the
end of your presentation
you mentioned about the panel that you
use
is a pan-ethnic panel
how important is it to use a pan-ethnic
panel
for carrier screening in today's society
and particularly in a population such as
the malaysian
yeah thank you very much for that
question yeah so malaysian population
like many
uh uh is a mixed population here we have
about indians in
malays chinese and others more
minorities from punjab so it's a very
complex uh population here in malaysia
so i think it's very very important that
we don't have
we don't use smaller panels target
panels for
populations like ours and it gives us a
lot of opportunity to
use a single panel that is suitable for
the entire population
and especially if you if you were to use
this kind of panels in
ivf centers as you know the in ivf
centers is an
arm you have a lot of patients coming
from different societies different
populations
especially from overseas if you are
promoting medical tourism so you will
have patience for coming from china
india you know so many countries will be
coming to ivf clinic
so if you were to have a smaller panel
target panels
you will not be addressing to these uh
diverse populations so i think it's
really really
important to have a broad expanded
carrier screening panel
that can be used for any given ethnicity
and so we find these kind of panels are
very useful when compared to the
previous panels that we were using
more focused to local population
and it addresses to private mutations
that are in
in small minority populations especially
in
consanguines marriages yeah but
i hope that answers the question
great thank you dr celine so another
question
that we've got come through is that
someone they're screening
for common single gene disorders or just
a few common
single gene disorders would you
recommend that they switch to expanded
carrier screening
and why yeah definitely i would
recommend to use an expanded rather than
a small single
targeted panel because for the reasons
that i just mentioned
earlier our populations are getting very
diverse
so if you use small gene panel or
you'll be only addressing very few
mutations and you will be
not addressing the complete uh risk
assessment
for that couple because when we do an
expanded carry screening and you're
looking at how
about 400 over genes so the risk
assessment
that we give for the couple is a very
comprehensive one
but if you use a smaller focus panel for
that ethnic group
you are not addressing the entire
risk for the couple and so that the risk
assessment that we give will be very
limited uh
so therefore the chances of missing an
important mutation
is much higher when you use a smaller
panel when compared with a larger panel
right and another question that we have
relates to variants of unknown
significance
and when you're doing the sequencing do
you get any variants of unknown
significance and what is your reporting
mechanism
so of course when you do an expanded
category you will get
uncertain significant changes that are
not reported in the literature
so at genomics lab we do not report the
variance of uncertain significance
because i believe that it has no role in
reproductive genetics unless of course
the problem has grown the family history
to show that this mutation
is associated with the phenotype that
they are describing
unless otherwise they present with this
kind of information we do not
report the variance of unknown
significance
but we keep all these records so that
they can
reset um the data on our subsequent
pregnancy
and we of course what we do is we will
be
looking at the data every every month to
see whether there is any change in this
interpretation and if there is any
change in the interpretation we will
immediately
inform the couple that there is a change
in the interpretation so that
they can plan the pregnancy for the
subsequent pregnancy
so once you offer an expanded kd
screening you only offer one time in a
lifetime
uh you don't have to repeat it for the
subsequent pregnancy you just have to
revisit the data to see if
any interpretation changes in those uh
especially those
variants of unknown significance so
in in a single line i think uh what the
answer is we don't report variance of
unknown significance unless there is a
reason to believe that it is uh
may show some phenotypic changes in that
family based on the clinical history
they are presenting
yeah i think we have time for one last
question and so
at the start of the presentation you
talked about combining
multiple tests into a single assay so
how much of a difference does that make
to your lab
it really makes a big difference because
um if you were to do multiple panels
like
mlpa we have to have about 10 kids doing
10 mlpa reactions
for 10 different copy number changes and
it occupies a lot of
time staff time and then analysis time
and also you'll be doing other targeted
pcr tests
so it consumes a lot of time to analyze
and run these tests
so with the shift into or to this
expanded carrier screening
uh the workflow is so really really easy
only one person is handling these
samples
and so
in the lab i think it's very very
convenient to have this expanded
schedule screen which
we really addresses to the copy number
changes plus uh
mutation screening and uh basic variant
calling
so it gives a lot of comfort and
for both the lab wet lab and also the
dry lab and also we are more comfortable
in reporting this data to our clients
in order to give a risk assessment to
these prospective couples
michael great thank you
very much dr celine
and thank you to the audience for the
questions that came through i'm sorry we
don't have time to
address all of those questions but those
that we didn't answer
we will try and address by email at a
later date
our next speaker in this session is dr
yong ju jiong the chief strategy officer
of the division of product development
at ferrari
genome care in south korea
genome care conducts genomic research
as well as offering genome-based testing
services
dr john will be sharing his experience
at genome care
and how they have been using the iron
torrent
next generation sequencing and
pre-implantation genetic testing
for reciprocal translocation carriers in
the korean population
i invite dr gion to give us his
presentation
over to you dr gion
let me just say thank you for taking
your time to be here
today as previously noticed
the subject of this presentation is
current status of pre-implantation
genetic testing
for reciprocal tensor location
in koreans the majority of critical
indication on pre-implementation gender
testing is benign carrier with genetic
problems
in korea and the number is being
steadily
increased in this time i'm here to
describe
our statistical data from the population
of benign translocation carriers between
september 2019 and may 2020
i'm going to give an overview of
geographic characteristics
and major indications of
pre-implantation genetic testing
pgt according to the report
from the productive biomedicine online
in
2017 about 3.3
thousands of ivf cycles was performed
globally and 263 000 of
ivf had a history of pgt
however a constitutive number of clinics
in
asia europe and performing pct
during ibf cycle in contrast to the
others
america australia and new zealand
the major three indications of pgt
are advanced maternal energy
repetitive implantation failure and the
current
pregnancy losses to be about 90 of
distribution
the next is statistical data of the
preferred
biopsy method to be used for pct
the frequencies of breast mia biopsy
and traffic acting biopsy to be executed
for
pct were 25
and 72 percent respectively
polar body biopsy may be carried out
due to pct but it was only three percent
this slide is the first statistical data
of
preferred test method to be used for
to pgt the frequencies
of racgh and next generation sequencing
to be executed for pgt were
59 and 16
respectively currently the next
generation sequencing method
ranked second in overall market share
but it is expected to be more widespread
and present the gradually increased late
to evaluate the pgt statistical data
from
benign carriers with genetic problems
it is necessary to review previous
historical data of pgt
for heritage disorders in january 2020
estimating review for unemployed
prevalence of pct cases where the
inherited disorders was published
in acta of obstetricians at
giant colossal scandinavia
all produce study data for from
pgtsr or pctm cases
the distribution of unemployed problems
ranged between 20 and
80 percent above half of the studies
the detected unemployed rate was more
than
30 percent
this slide present measures for clinical
outcomes after listening pgt
in contrast to the other conditions
the pct was shown in blue
and the others in green overall
the historical data have shown a
beneficial effect
of pct in maintaining pregnancy
classifical velocity translocation does
not produce
chromosomal copy number changes and
usually present benign phenotype
however the genetic problems may occur
in the next generation half
of of spring from normal and velocity
translocation carrier parents
may have abnormal chromosomal
capital number therefore the pgt
objective of balanced translocation
carrier
is generally too low out risk of
chromosomal microaddition or
micro duplication
the previous literature identified
beneficial effects on the balance
translocation
saving pgt in 2019
pgt contributed to reduce the risk
of birth defect and otherwise pregnancy
outcome
but increase the light of normal life
buzz
moreover the numbers of severe
congenital anomalies were significantly
lowered
after receiving pgt
there are three main objectives of this
survey
as follows first it is two
is transformable embryo prevalence
in korean balanced translocation
carriers
second is to consider
how many number of embryos may be
required
for at least one normal copy number
embryo
third it is to find out critical factors
including maternal energy and the
specific
causes and biopsy method associated with
the areas of
normal copy number embryos
we use the sequencing libraries with
ion the prostitute the pre-amplification
picture cycles was
of the turf ectoderm and blastomere were
12 cycles in 15 cycles respectively
the qc cut off of library concentration
was
10 nanogram per microliter
and final concentration of library
pulling
is 80 picomole for ion 6s5 sequencing
the data analysis was performed with
ion the printer version 5.10 software
and unemployed season filter was
applied to detect partial chromosomal
deletion duplication
the qc cutoff of uniquely mapped
sequencing lens
was 100 thousand
from september 2019
to may 2020 the test recourse
of 124 couples with
male or female benign trans location
carrier
were collected for this survey
table 1 represents demographic
characteristics
of ignored 124
couples data the mean female age was
36 with standard deviation
as 3.9 the couples with balanced
translocation
requested about six embryos on
ember average approximately
forty percent cases were made
translocation carrier
while sixty percent cases were female
translocation carrier
only one couple had both male and female
translocation carriers
above eighty percent of couples
were in the mind used using traffic
ectoderm biopsy 2 is called chromosomal
deletion duplication risk
table 2 demonstrates the prevalence
of normal copy number embryos according
to
age test number gender specific factors
and biopsy method of the 728
embryos about twenty percent of embryos
have normal copy number chromosomes
earlier female age and twelve acronym
biopsy
presented beneficial effects on
increased
yields of transferable embryos there
were no significant
differences in test number and gender
specific factors
table three describes the rate of
couples with
at least one transferable employee
regarding ag test number gender specific
factors
and biopsy method of the
124 couples
80 calls obtained at least one embryo
of normal chromosome number without
partial dilation or duplication
there were significant favorable effects
in the condition of below 40 years of
feminine age
over 6 tested embolus
biopsy
table 4 shows a proportion of couples
with
at least one embryo with above
3 multiple unemployees of the 124
couples 95 couples had at
least one embryo with over three
multiple copy number operations
the frequencies of the embryo with
multiple unemployees
were higher in advanced female age
and blastomere biopsy
table 5 presently attendance late
of couples with at least 1 embryos
of normal copy number in previous pct
tests of 80 couples
only nine couples had experiences
of lead attendance the despite the
presence
of normal copy number embryo in
gt test advanced female age was
associated with an increasedly attendant
slate
implying adverse pregnancy outcomes
in conclusion we could find the
significant
factors affecting use of transformable
embryos from the statistical data of
translocation carriers receiving pgt
first the conditions with below
40 years of female 8 and 12 ectoderm
biopsy
were recommended to increase yields of
embryos
with the normal copper number second
of tested embryo were approximately
six to achieve about eighty percent
use of a transvaable embryo with a
normal copy number third
male balanced translocation factor
presented the negative effects
on use of normal copy number embryos
it is the end of this presentation thank
you for listening
okay thank you so much thank you so much
okay
sorry i think there's been some
technical issue with my audio
sorry michelle back yeah so thank you dr
john for the
wonderful insight into your
pre-implantation genetic testing for
reciprocal translocations
in south korea and sharing your
experience with us
i will now open this session for
questions and a reminder if you do have
any questions
please submit them via the q a box
so we have a few questions that are
coming in
and the first question we have dr john
is what was the distribution
of the translocation size in the
enrolled couples of this study
the distribution of the
location size was from 4 megapixels
okay second question
that we have is
what is the definition
of re-attendance can you
expand what is what does that mean
uh the definition is the case is
okay another question that we have and
i'm gonna ask you to speak up a little
dr john it's a little soft
was the case of both male and female
translocation carriers able to find
a normal embryo
[Music]
um
so what was the follow-up for that
couple did they
do another cycle
okay and
you mentioned you showed data at the
beginning
of the presentation around
array cgh and next generation sequencing
so what advantage does next generation
sequencing have over array cgh
for pre-implantation genetic testing for
reciprocal translocations
[Music]
benefit does next
sequencing give for detecting
[Music]
reciprocal translocation
[Music]
for pgtt
[Music]
around around 3 000
around around three hundred
hundred
thousand
okay so i think for those
more technical questions we can address
them
later via email
so
i'm still waiting for a couple more
questions to come in
via chat
and we've not got any more questions
coming in
so thank you again dr jung
and i would like to thank the audience
for that participation
and we will try and answer any questions
that you do submit after
we'll try and answer those via email at
a later date
so once again thank you very much dr
jeong for that
great presentation
our last speaker for this session
is dr ritu hari from craft hospital
india ritu
is a certified genetic counselor
and she holds a phd in reproductive
genetics from the united kingdom
dr ritu heads the pgt the pgd
laboratory at craft hospital and is
credited with performing
india's first pgt for monogenic
disorders
for a taste mutation carrier couple
leading to a live birth as well as
a successful live birth from an smn1
mutation carrier couple
and has been involved in many other pgtm
cases
dr ritu has published many chapters and
articles in reputed journals and books
and was part of the pgd consensus to
frame the guidelines for india
as an as an initiative from the indian
society
for assisted reproduction
welcome dr ritu
good morning everybody uh first of all i
would like to
thank thermo fisher team for giving me
this opportunity to present
uh the reproductive genetic based
services
on ngs i have been a customer
and have been using thermo fisher's ngs
platform iron s5 excel from past
five years now and i'm into mostly
reproductive genetics based tests
like pgs pgd nipt
and even clinical exome and we have
recently introduced pgtm
also on ngs so in my today's
presentation
i'm going to be talking about what
different levels of genetic
investigations in what different levels
of pregnancies can these genetic
investigations be done
and uh what are the diff what are the
what are the number of advantages a
single platform like
ngs can provide us
so basically the genetic culprits in
any kind of pregnancy be it a natural
pregnancy or an
ivf related pregnancy miscarriages
due to chromosomal abnormalities are
seen in a higher rate
whichever pregnancy is getting
spontaneously aborted before three
months
of pregnancy are said to be caused due
due to 80 percentage of the times due to
chromosomal problems
so these chromosomal problems they form
the hallmark
which are very important and what we
refer to as
as what we refer to as aniploidy
now euplody is something uh individual
having
normal set of chromosomes that is 23
pairs and unemployed is something which
is plus
plus one chromosome or minus one
chromosome or plus or minus multiple
chromosomes
which are not compatible with human life
now conception is definitely god's
gifted
thing but then when conception some
conceptions carry on to normal delivery
to normal
pregnancy and delivery at term but some
conceptions can miscarry before three
months
mainly due to chromosomal problems so
those are referred to as
an employee pregnancies and then there
are some
dna related problems basically genetic
problems are classified into chromosomal
and dna related problems
in dna related problems like conditions
like spinal muscular atrophy thalassemia
tests etc
parents are carriers of any known
genetic condition
so these dna related problems will not
cause
miscarriage in the couple but can go on
to produce children who can be
genetically abnormal if they are
carriers of any known mutation so now
on ngs we can tackle both chromosomal
related problems
dna related problems and also
genome-wide problems
so
now what are the levels of genetic
investigation
traditionally in earlier days uh we had
only prenatal diagnosis
that is when a fetus is formed in the
mother's
womb and around 12 weeks of pregnancy we
do a chorionic village sampling to
diagnose whether a fetus is affected
with a genetic problem or a chromosomal
problem depending on the indication
now uh now we are in the era of
pre-implantation genetic diagnosis or
testing where we can diagnose these
abnormalities in the embryo level
and that has happened because of the
greater technologies like
ngs and then we also have something
called
post natal genetic diagnosis now when i
say postnatal
that is after the birth of a child if
there is any abnormality we can do a
clinical exam sequencing that is we can
cover
all the coding regions of the genome or
the dna and we can come to know as to
what
genetic problem exists in the child
index
child we can offer them a targeted
screening now
in my subsequent slides i have put an
example of all this and shown how these
different screening methodologies can be
applied
and then we have something called
expanded carrier screening as well
now exam let's have a scenario exam can
be done
on a couple who have had a child with
abnormality and they are suspecting to
be genetic
in nature and we so that we can take
care in the next pregnancy we can offer
them an exome sequencing
many of the times the couple can lose
the child that is the index child may be
no longer surviving so in those cases we
can offer them an expanded carrier
screening on the couple where we can
come to know what actually the genetic
basis of the disease was
and targeted screening is something
where you know which gene can be
affected depending on the clinical
features or clinical manifestation and
the geneticist can advise a targeted
screen
so all these kind of genetic
investigations are possible on ngs in a
single platform
[Music]
so now coming to the technologies uh in
the embryo level the first generation
of pgs or pgd or pgta what we call now
we had the fish technology where limited
number of chromosomes were checked
from then started the science of
pre-plantation genetic testing on
embryos though fish did not prove to be
very effective in
determining the clinical pregnancy rate
we
still the research went on and then
array cth was developed
array cgh is a technique where known
samples can be used as
controls and then you can have unknown
samples tested against them
but the only problem with array series
was only limited number of samples can
be run together
and then uh after rscgh even
the ngs platform was developed and we
had the first baby born in 2013 after
performing pgs on ngs
we have ins five excel in our laboratory
where we offer pgtam
and sr for our uh couples so in ngs the
basic advantage of performing
multiplexing that is you can run up to
20 from 24 to 396 embryos
and then you can multiply them together
providing lot of clinical information so
that is the advantage of nds over fish
or rapidges the accuracy
increases there is a high increase of
likelihood of accuracy
now there is something called time lapse
where debate is still going on time
lapse is a technology where
people are using it to determine the
morpho kinetics of the embryo
determining the morpho kinetic
itself might not be very helpful because
we need to know the genotype as well
so both genotyping using ngs technology
and also the time lapse morpho kinetic
can actually increase the pregnancy rate
in an infra child couple
so these are the technologies now any
challenges
before pregnancy a couple trying to
conceive for years can be either
recurrent pregnancy laws as i have
mentioned
or can be recurrent iv or failures after
putting top quality blastocyst if the
pregnancy gets failed
failed to achieve we have uh come across
many scenarios like that so what next
can be investigated
and on these couples already the factors
like endocrine biochemical immunological
factors have been ruled out
so in our country like india still there
are some
debates and controversies where
clinicians do not accept genetics or
genetic
investigation as part of infertility
treatment
they are least ignored they are ignored
but then we cannot
ignore that is not the answer we need to
have a basic investigation of
karyotyping done on couples and then
only we will be able to
further tell what could be the next role
of
treatment so how we can evaluate the
success
with pgta pgta is for checking
chromosomal anemia
so we know that two thirds of clinical
miscarriages are always caused
because of chromosomal animoides and
some unemployees may be observed in
miscarriages and some may
not be observed because some pregnancies
can get aborted even though
even before it has got clinically
confirmed so that can be
under the category of implantation or
developmental lethal the embryos may get
arrested and may not give rise to
pregnancy
so ivf implantation also decreases with
increasing age and we know that with the
increase in age the unemployed
rates in among elder women also
increases so natural pregnancies also
have an age related
risk where you can have higher incidence
of trisomy 21
so these are some of the causes why ngs
based pgta should be offered to couples
now how do i convince my patients for
pgt in my lab
even though the normal karyotype of
couples are usually seen
there might be unemployed and embryos
because pre implantation stage embryos
can have aneploides
even the mitotic errors should not be
ignored anything which is growing in
vitro that is outside the human body can
give rise to anechoidis so even mitotic
errors
beat okay mitotic error should also not
be ignored so you should advise the
couple
meiotic errors are something we know
that it is present so that is
gamete related or couple related both
meiotic and mitotic errors can be well
taken care
so maternal meiotic errors are more high
in advanced
age and even paternal meiotic errors can
be high especially when you are running
a male in fertility clinic because
when you see a lot of males with asus
permea that is zero sperm count
you can have a lot of meiotic errors in
their dna so that can also give rise to
unemployed
in their embryos and post meiotic
abnormalities are also common in younger
women there are many recent articles
which
throws light on that and unemployed as i
said in advanced metallurgy movement is
also
present so these are some of the
convincing facts which can be talked to
the patient
now this is one of the report of our
laboratory where i wanted to highlight
uh you can select the most viable
blastocysts
blastocyst even the mitochondrial dna
ratio can be predicted uh in a single
run
in the same biopsy you can get a lot of
clinical information
apart from knowing the antichrist status
you can get to know the mitochondrial
dna ratio also so in this case uh there
are four
embryos which are found to be euploid or
normal and they are recommended for
transfer
the other one you can see here it is an
undiagnosed where the dna of the embryo
dna from the embryo was not sufficient
enough for us to define
whether it is normal or abnormal so in
such scenarios you can leave the
decision between patient and the
clinician
so coming to an ngscario map this is one
of the carrier map which shows
all the comprehensive pair of
chromosomes being screened here
and obviously this is abnormal to
transfer it has a monotony of chromosome
number nine which is red
color here and a monotony of chromosome
14. so you can see even though the
karyotype
was normal the uh pre-implantation
genetic testing of one of the embryo
revealed abnormality in chromosome 9 and
14. so it can be due to either meiotic
reason or mitotic reason
this is of course not fit for transfer
now another important point i wanted to
focus here ngs calls the mosaic status
of the embryos much better than aracgh
a mosaic is something you have different
cell lines that is one cell line having
normal chromosomal compound
complement and other cell line can have
different chromosomal complement
so in comparison to array series this
was a case where it was misdiagnosed by
ra cgh but then correctly picked up by
ngs
now genetic evaluation of recurrent
spontaneous aborted samples is also one
of the area which is
now very much picking up in the regular
obstetric organic practice
the traditional method of fetal
karyotyping was cell culture methods
where
uh geneticist 99 percent of the time
fails to give the result because of the
cell culture failure of the abortions
now thanks to the technologies like ngs
where we can actually
there is no need to go ahead with the
regular culture method you can extract
the dna from the abortions
do a maternal cell contamination check
and then
go ahead with the ngs testing and then
you can give the ploidy result
so this is one of the results from my
lab where trisomy 16 fetus was detected
in one of the abortions
the first uh figure here then monozomix
was detected in the next fetus
and then we have a trisomy 22 fetus
showing up the abnormality
so such kind of abnormalities can be
picked up in
uh if you do a karyotype for the product
of conceptus
now why it is important to do a
karyotype because
even though some patients might not do a
regular karyotyping or a basic
karyotyping
they will not know the reason of their
recurrent spontaneous abortion
so doing one at least one abortive
stereotyping will reveal if that
particular unemployed is getting
recurrent in the pregnancies or it's not
getting recurrent
monozomia x can be due to sometimes x
chromosomal problem
abnormalities in the mothers or can be
due to in the father as well so it's
always better to
offer a karyotyping of the parents
before you
have them in your ivf link
so parental karyotyping is very very
important there are no specific
guidelines in india but as a personal
experience
even as you can see in this case even
this particular female was low
i mean less in age though her maternal
age was less
and she had a second miscarriage when we
had some suspicion we did our
karyotyping and it was revealed that she
is a balanced
robertsonian translocation between
chromosome 13 and 14.
so this female could have suffered more
miscarriages
and we would not have known the genetic
reasons we would have investigated the
other investigation but could have
missed
so she is a candidate of pgp sr
now i'll be speaking about pgtsr in my
next slide
so in such scenarios we it is must to
have a karyotype done so that we can
advise them for
further treatment so pgtsr is something
as i have shown you in the karyotype
there is a breakage of one particular
segment of chromosome
and the other segment of chrome and the
the particular segment get attaches to
the other segment of any part of
chromosome
so such uh scenarios are referred to as
balance translocation where the female
or male
can be carriers of the balance
translocation and they can be normal
but when they reproduce problems pop up
in their gametes
and their reproduct and the gametes or
the embryo embryos
which turns after the fertilization
where we can see lot of abnormalities
due to those translocations
now those translocation abnormalities
can actually be picked up
in ngs and we refer to as pgtsr
the dilemma or the irony of indian
scenario of
not offering pdtsr in those couples we
wait for three abortions
but then if patients are willing if you
have a karyotype then if you have an
answer you cannot even offer them with a
one with one or two abortions
because you don't want the patient to
miscarry it it
creates a lot of psychological issues
among the patients
so this is one of again one of the cases
where a female is 34 years she was
presented to us with primary infertility
her stereotype revealed translocation
between chromosome 2 and 13.
now interestingly this couple did not
have any uh
abortions but the reason was primary
infertility she never conceived
now some translocations unlike the
robertsonian translocation can give rise
to implantation failures the couple may
not even recognize whether they got
pregnant anytime
so such cases actually it is easily
being dealt by pgt
sr only thing is you need to counsel the
embryo you
need to counsel the patients to have
more number of embryos
so that you have you can send them home
with a baby with a good take home baby
weight so we counseled them
we biopsied around 10 embryos and we
transferred one normal embryo
and now we have an ongoing pregnancy so
this is her report
we could do a biopsy on day three and
then
we could get the dna in all these you
can see quality control had been passed
in all the embryos all the ten embryos
and out of that only one was normal so
we now have a clinical
ongoing clinical pregnancy so this is
the data from one of our embryos where
correctly the
ngs has picked up the segmental
not the segmental the whole chromosome
uh unbalanced translocation
she had a translocation between 2 and 13
so it has been packed very nicely
chromosome 2 there is a blue line
suggesting trisomy three copies and
chromosome
13 a red line suggesting a monozomy that
is one copy of chromosome 13.
this was one of the examples now we do
something called targeted mutation
testing which is also possible in ngs
we can sequence the suspected gene like
fibroblast growth packaging in one of my
cases
also beta hydrogen is gene which causes
a tail sex disease
now a couple
came to me three years almost three
years back for genetic counselling
couple uh in the couple male side had no
family history but
male had skeletal dysplasia he underwent
skeletal extension but no genetic
investigation was done
the suspected gene was of course sgfr3
where i ordered for a targeted mutation
screening on
indians and interestingly we found a
mutation in one of the
exons here so he was a candidate for
pgpm that is monogenic defect because
they had a history of primary
infertility and the never conceived
husband has some feminine abnormalities
and sperm abnormalities
so they were candidates for ivf and then
pgpm they wanted it
because there is a 50 chance for them to
have an affected child
so we have ongoing we already have
twins born out of this particular parent
they we could do a pgtm on them and then
we have now twins who are one year old
this is one of the successful cases now
coming to monogenic diseases
you have autism and resistance
conditions where both parents
can be carriers and there is a 25 risk
of transmitting
you have autosomal dominant condition as
i have shown in my example you have 50
percent
of it to get transmitted and then you
have excellent resistance
example hemophilia dushing muscular
dystrophy etc where mother can be
carriers
and she can pass on the defective gene
to her son
so ngs has made it very much possible
through a very robust indirect approach
where you can offer
pgtm for any type of genetic condition
provided you have a family history the
mutation should
not be dean over that is the
family one father or the mother or the
grandparent should have that mutation
that is referred to as linkage based
analysis
now linkage based analysis has been
traditionally used in all the pgtm cases
earlier
where few linkage markers around that
particular gene was developed for any
disease
namely two or three linkage linkage
markers were used and which are
informative
you know are diagnosed accordingly so in
ngs
it is basically pan-ethnic population
where we can use up to 200 to 300 smps
for linkage based analysis and we can
generate a haplotype of the embryo
here you can use grandmother that is the
parent's parent sample if you suspect a
family history and then
the parent sample and then the embryo
sample and if you have an affected child
already even the affected child sample
can be used
and imagine the accuracy of ngs based
technique that you can generate
million number of reads across any
embryo across any parent sample and then
compare them
so linkage based analysis is generally
comparison between these controls and
the
embryos we generate and gives us an
accurate report
the advantage of doing a linkage based
based analysis is you can
reduce allele drop out to even nil even
zero i have done
three four cases by using the ngs based
panels
in my laboratory and i have seen good
results
so coming to the data analysis part of
the linkage phase analysis
the orange one is actually affected here
the green one is normal that is the wild
type you have male and female who are
carriers of a resistive condition and
child who is affected
these are the embryos the embryo one
here is basically
affected there is two red the second
embryo is the carriers
the third ember is also carrier and the
fourth embryo is normal which has the
wild kaipali
now this kind of phasing is usually done
by a special software which is which
comes along with the panel
and after the phasing you can generate
alleles accordingly you can compare them
using a linkage based study and then
give the give embryos a genotype
now a case study where we did recently
and
here clinical pregnancy is just ongoing
a female age 29 years was found to be
affected with huntington's and here is
her report
where 73 base pair allele was repeated
and this is a repeat expansion disorder
we did a indirect approach based pgtm
here
we took the sample from father her
father is basically affected with the
huntington condition
and her mother was normal so we used
mother sample father
sample and the daughter sample against
which we controlled we
compared with embryos so we had actually
biopsied around 10
embryos and out of 10 embryos we had
one two and three being normal so we
have transferred one of the embryos only
one embryo clicked and that resulted in
the clinical pregnancy
so one embryo we could not give any
conclusive results
based on the data generated so here
we can say it's an indirect approach
because we do not know the
we we just know the diseased part of the
gene that is
in such repeated expansion disorder like
fragile x or huntington's
linkage analysis is the best and it
serves the purpose because you can know
the location of the gene as well
our second case built here was for
estimates spinal muscular atrophy
where couples were carriers of exon 7
deletion they had lost two children
before
we explained them the risks and they
wanted to go ahead with
the indirect method that is haplotyping
why indirect here exon 7 is a bigger
deletion so we need to define the
linkage or snp is based on that
particular gene
so we collected grandparent sample
12 embryos were tested again and four
normal was there
and patient had transfer of one normal
embryo and she delivered a healthy baby
baby is now eight months old
so these are some of the success stories
of our pgtm based
ngs platform this is the result where we
could biopsy around
12 embryos and we have also done a pgta
i wanted to highlight though this is a
normal embryo for
smn exon 7 there is no deletion but it
is a trisomy 13 embryo
so had it been we did not do a pgta we
could have wrongly transferred this
embryo which would have led to pregnancy
loss either pregnancy loss or
this particular chromosome is compatible
with live birth of course we would have
advised nipt things like that but then
in the embryo level itself if you can
buy off in the same stage of biopsy if
you can come to know both pgtm and pgta
results then there is no harm in telling
the patient
but my only advice is after offering
pgtm
after getting the pgtm results only you
should be offering pgta
so the clinical advantages of ngs is it
improve
implantation rates for some patients for
patients with pgta pgpsr
it decreases unnecessary transfer for
most patient types that is young
imagine a cohort of young patient who
has more embryos
on day five we do not know which one to
transfer
so in such cases you can actually after
offering them a pgt
you can know which is euclid and which
is anechoid so that you don't transfer
any ploid embryos
it of course decreases miscarriage rates
and minimizes miscarriage rate
especially for advanced medical age
women and translocation carriers
as i have shown before you can also
offer a single embryo transfer cycle as
a real option without losing pregnancy
rates
and also you can avoid multiple
gestations these are some of the
clinical advantages
of offering engineers and yes uh
technically it has high throughput
it has the cost has been drastically
come down by using by multiplexing
technology and using barcodes
you can offer both pgta sr or m
in the same experiment you get
additional genetic information which is
clinically relevant and of course it
reduces time to pregnancy
so now one of the important signs
now we are coming to is nipt nipt
is being done from quite long now and
nowadays many indian laboratories are
actually replacing triple test or
quadruple test
regular biochemical screening with nipt
so this
is uh one i don't have much time to
cover nipt
the in this nutshell nipt is
non-invasive prenatal testing which is
offered to pregnant women at 11 weeks
or 10 weeks 10 to 11 weeks uh that can
it can be offered after 11 weeks also
but in our
clinical setups we advise them at 10 to
11 weeks
cell free dna which is present in a
various very smaller
amount passes through the placenta and
then
flows into the mother's bloodstream in
ipt we do not
sequence only the fragments of fetal dna
we sequence both maternal and fetal dna
both
and of course we do a counting method
using mps-based technology which is
massive parallel frequency and counting
method tells us
whether the fetus is at risk of having a
trisomy or not for a
this is a full comprehensive chromosome
result from our laboratory where we
screen up to 23 pairs of chromosomes
x chromosomes are not revealed unless we
see any
abnormality abnormalities in the sex
chromosome
another advantage personal advantage i
have seen of offering nipt
is sex chromosomal abnormalities like
monozomix triploidy triplex
cannot be picked up by regular
biochemical methods or even ultrasound
scan cannot pick these abnormalities
because only once the baby is born with
such problems we will come to know
so the advantage of having an nipt done
for all ivf pregnancies i would say
is you can get to know the sex
chromosomal abnormalities well in
advance for us to take a clinical
decision
with this i would like to conclude thank
you very much i hope i have covered all
the reproductive genetic services and
techniques which can be performed on ngs
thank you very much for your kind
attention
thank you dr ritsu for sharing those
inspiring stories and detailing how you
are combining both pre-implantation
genetic testing
for aneuploidy as well as for
pre-implantation genetic
genetic testing for those monogenic
disorders using a single
next-generation sequencing platform
saving both time
and cost while helping those couples
have healthy
babies i am now going to open
the session for questions and again i
encourage you all
to put your questions into the chat box
and we'll relay those to dr ritu
and i see a few questions that are
coming through
and not sure exactly what this one
relates to
but the question here
dr ritzer is although ngs
is advantageous over fish
in several experiments fish is still
used
apart from the reason that ngs is not
available
for that lab are there any other reasons
why fish is being used
all right i think
[Music]
is
um
there's a bit of echo and a bit of
breaking up
in your yeah
what kind of test would you suggest the
patient to start with if there
is no family history then pgta
plus carrier type in first what would be
your recommendation
what kind of right kind of
uh
that the voice is very breaking up and
we can't really understand
that's much clearer
all right
[Music]
is
foreign
michael michael yeah okay um
so next question that we have here is
can genetic testing be done on
myometrium
if there is frequent miscarriage
okay we will take that question and
address that via email
at a uh after the event
another question is
in the smn case you presented why did
you need to use the grandparents
and was this maternal or paternal
grandparents
eternal side grandmother
[Music]
uh
okay i think we're going to close the q
a session the end of that
session now and i apologize if there's
any questions that we did not have time
to answer
okay but again i'd like to thank dr
ritter
and the audience for their participation
as well as uh
both dr felim and uh dr young ju
okay so this really concludes their
webinar sessions for today
just a reminder the virtual conference
environment
will remain live and open so please do
drop
by the booth especially the reproductive
health booth
where you can interact with us and find
out more information about
any of the reproductive health genetic
solutions that we have available
to help you accelerate your research you
can also
participate in the scavenger hunt game
you're looking out for the icons that
you will find in the conference
environment and the exhibit area
collect those icons and you stand a
chance to win some prizes
please i also encourage you to complete
the pop-up survey
that will appear shortly and again
i just would like to thank you all
hopefully that you will be able to join
us tomorrow for more talks
on our solutions in reproductive health
so thank you everybody and stay safe
you